[Musique]
le cadre lumineux de cette non très
radioactifs cela n'est pourtant pas le
signe annonciateur de la fin des temps
la radioactivité naturelle et
artificielle existe en permanence autour
de nous elle existe déjà naturellement
ici à fessenheim dans cinq ans sur cet
emplacement la centrale nucléaire de
l'edf produira de l'électricité et à
l'aide de ce même compteur geiger l'on
constatera alors avec étonnement que
notre monde était deux fois plus
radioactive que les alentours de cette
centrale
mais cette affirmation bien sûr ne
résout pas la somme de question que l'on
peut se poser sur cet équipement
nucléaire est tout d'abord sur son
utilité
nous avons à les délais la possibilité
de faire d'énergie électrique ce fut
trois façons d'abord l'hydraulique qui a
été largement employés par le passé mais
qui malheureusement arrive à sa fin vous
savez qu'actuellement on peut produire
environ 55 milliards de kilowattheures
par an mais que en équipant tous qu'il
reste possible de barrage en france on
arrivera tout juste à 60 milliards de
kilowattheures or la consommation
doublant tous les dix ans ces 400
milliards de kilowattheures il faudra en
1985 et tout le reste il faut le faire
par l'énergie thermique
les exemples présent montrent qu'il est
difficile d'avoir une sécurité totale
d'approvisionnement quand le fuel oil
n'existe pas en france et c'est ainsi
que tout naturellement et avenay
se diriger vers cette énergie cette
nouvelle source d'énergie
cette nouvelle source d'énergie celle
uranium minerais dont la france est
particulièrement riche puisque
l'extraction constituent actuellement
chez nous près de 10% de la production
mondiale
c'est un détail important lorsque l'on
sait que les ressources minérales ne
sont pas inépuisables
ainsi grâce à l'énergie nucléaire la
réduction de ses importations seront
obtenus et les kilowattheures thermiques
et nucléaires auront le même prix de
revient la partie circuit
thermodynamique est la même dans son
principe dans une centrale classique et
râle nucléaire la seule différence
réside dans la nature des phénomènes qui
sont mises en jeu pour produire la
chaleur dans le cas d'une centrale à
charbon
la chaleur est obtenu par combustion du
charbon par une réaction chimique qui
consiste à brûler le carbone qui ont
extrait du sol à l'aide de l'oxygène que
l'on prend dans l'air pour fixer les
idées une centrale de la puissance de
celle de fessenheim au charbon
utiliserait de l'ordre de 3 millions de
tonnes de charbon par an utiliserait
pour brûler ce charbon de l'ordre de 7
millions de tonnes d'oxygène qui serait
par conséquent pris sur les autres
besoin d'oxygène de la terre et
restituerait par sa cheminée de l'ordre
de 10 millions de tonnes de gaz
carbonique et de produits de combustion
divers par ailleurs les cendres
sont en quantité importante puisqu'elle
serait de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de tonnes de l'ordre de 500
mille tonnes au contraire dans une
centrale nucléaire
le phénomène physique qui est utilisé
pour produire la chaleur c'est la
réaction de fission nucléaire et qui ne
met en jeu que les propriétés propres de
l'uranium
indépendamment de tout apport extérieur
et qui utilise pour cela des quantités
d'uranium extraordinairement plus
faibles le coeur de la centrale de
fessenheim de 900 mégawatts
on comprend environ 70 tonnes d'uranium
et 70 tonnes et qui normalement peuvent
être utilisés pendant trois ans c'est à
dire que la quantité de combustible
annuellement utilisé est de l'ordre de
25 ans seulement
actuellement la production française et
environ 2 200 milliards de
kilowattheures mais en 1985 l'on
envisage déjà grâce à la seule énergie
nucléaire
une production de 400 milliards de
kilowattheures c'est dire que pour faire
face à un tel accroissement des besoins
l'edf se doit de mettre en service
autant de moyens de production qu'il en
existait il ya dix ans à cette époque
déjà la france avait été une des
premières nations à produire de
l'électricité d'origine nucléaire est
une des premières nations a constaté la
compétitivité du nucléaire
et c'est bien cette notion de
compétitivité qui fut déterminante dans
le choix de l'alsace au coeur du marché
commun pour la construction de cette
nouvelle centrale nucléaire
[Musique]
m
ce site a été choisi à fessenheim d'une
part pour le
l'importance de la source froide et
d'autre part pour permettre une
expansion de la zone industrielle de du
haut rhin et en même temps permettent d
exportation de courant vers le reste de
la france
une voie fluviale à grand gabarit pour
le refroidissement des condenseurs de la
centrale une région en pleine expansion
au centre de l'europe
on le voit la za c'était tout
naturellement désigné pour cette
implantation
pourtant et comme toujours en pareil cas
les protestations n'ont pas tardé à se
faire entendre pour le grand public en
effet tout ce qui touche à l'énergie
nucléaire en permanence dans nous et
autour de nous évoque l'idée de bombes
atomiques et de dégénérescence génétique
pourtant la protection contre le
rayonnement est contre la dispersion des
déchets radioactifs est très largement
garantie et peu de technique mêmes
peuvent se flatter de prendre autant de
précautions contre les nuisances
[Musique]
quand on parle de l'énergie nucléaire
tout le monde est inquiet parce que
l'énergie nucléaire est rentré à la
connaissance du public à l'occasion des
bombes de la fin de la dernière guerre
et effectivement les effets destructeurs
des bombes sont assez terrifiant il n'a
pourtant aucune espèce de commune mesure
entre une bombe et une centrale
nucléaire
physiquement elle et les matériaux qui
sont mis en oeuvre ne sont pas les mêmes
et des strictement impossible d'une
centrale nucléaire puisse devenir une
bombe à la suite de quelques incidents
que ce soit ceci étant quelque chose
malheur est bon
le fait que c'est que la radioactivité
que l'énergie nucléaire soit intervenu
avec cet aspect terrifiant fait que
lancer préoccuper dès le début des
précautions à prendre pour se protéger
contre ses effets nocifs et que dans ce
domaine là plus que dans beaucoup
d'autres on a mis effectivement les
bleus devant la charrue c'est à dire
qu'on s'est préoccupée des protections
avant de réaliser les installations et
on ne peut pas en dire autant de toutes
les installations industrielles
d'anciennes pour lesquels on à
progresser pas à pas et on s'est aperçu
souvent bien après qu'il y avait des
nuisances importantes
ces écrans sont calculés de façon à ce
que la dose de rayonnement subi oqali et
affronter un travailleur qui a pénétré
dans l'enceinte que cette dose
rayonnement soit dans tous les cas
inférieur aux normes ou normes de
radioprotection l'edf est conscient du
danger que représentent les rayonnements
elle sait que les besoins d'énergie de
notre société ne doivent pas aller à
l'encontre du cadre de vie sain
indispensables à la population et c'est
au cours de débats avec le public comme
celui ci que les deux aspects du
problème son analyse oui dans leur
principe même les réacteurs nucléaires
sont dangereux mais ni en france ni à
irin ya eu accident de personne
alain et bien personnellement je ne
pense pas que l'installation d'une
centrale nucléaire pose deux problèmes
de santé au niveau des populations comme
je ne pense pas non plus qu'elle impose
au niveau des personnes qui sont chargés
d'exploiter ses centrales nucléaires
vous savez effectivement que les agents
qui exploite la centrale hydraulique de
fessenheim habite fessenheim et
comme les agents qui supporteront la
centrale nucléaire habits trop également
fessenheim c'est par conséquent que
électricité de france a bien conscience
de ne pas exposer les familles de ses
agents en danger quelconque est ce qui
te équipe en tête le public sait c'est
ce qu'on va faire des déchets
radioactifs oui la question
effectivement nous est souvent posée
je dois dire que cette question ne nous
intéresse pas directement du fait que
dans nos centrales nucléaires nous ne
produisons pratiquement que très peu de
déchets radioactifs dans quelques années
au centre de cette image le réacteur
nucléaire de fessenheim produira sa
formidable quantité d'énergie et cette
énergie coïncidera non pas avec le
déclin de l'alsace mais plutôt avec son
essor
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]